alors nous y voici nous y voilà mesdames
m
aujourd'hui je serais de vous partager
une proposition deux visions la vie dont
vous êtes le héros joueurs avant de
rentrer dans une histoire mais pas
n'importe quelle histoire
je vais vous poser une première question
quel est votre jeu préféré
eh oui rien que ça votre jeu préféré
attention ici il est question du jeu de
plateau du jeu de rôle du jeu de monde
peut-être pour certains tout ce qui va
correspondre à l'univers du jeu mais ce
qui est important c'est les celui qui à
vous donner envie de rejouer de relance
et d'y retourner encore et encore même
sans savoir pourquoi ce qui peut parfois
nous animer dans ce jeu là et alors
qu'une partie de vos va pouvoir
réfléchir et voir de plus en plus les
liens avec ce jeu préféré au fil de
cette vision on va commencer une
histoire et comme toute histoire
elle va commencer par les mots magiques
il était une fois oui il était une fois
vous pouvez vous rappeler de ces mots
ces mots que vous avez pu entendre alors
que vous étiez plus jeune ou même encore
vous avez encore des contes des mots qui
précédait une suite de récits une suite
d' aventure émotion parfois même de
philosophie d'enchaînements avec des
personnages plus ou moins charismatique
voire même des anti héros il paraît que
c'est à la mode aujourd'hui
mais ce qui était une fois il va être
pour vous parce qu'aujourd'hui nous
arrivons à votre histoire une histoire
qui vous a mené à cette période là
maintenant tout de suite à cette
conférence une histoire de vous êtes
tous le personnage principal une
histoire qui a commencé dès votre
première inspiration est votre regard
sur le monde
la visite vous vous êtes le héros
ayrault sérieusement vous - héros non
non attendez les avengers est pas là non
non non par contre si vous considérez
que un héros cela définition c'est
simplement le personnage principal
d'une oeuvre d'une histoire alors je
crois que vous avez tout fait une
histoire que vous avez commencé non
selon la légende aussi le héros vivrait
une succession d'aventurés et il serait
connecté à quelque chose de plus grand
que lui
ce quelque chose de plus grand à
l'aventuré d'afif est à définir
par contre est-ce que vous savez ce qui
vous rapproche vous tous oui de ses
héros et de ce héros que vous êtes
eh bien ce sont les choix que ce soit un
héros qu'il va faire un choix entre une
pilule rouge ou une pub qui va le mener
à la réalité que ce soit un héros qui va
décider de porter un halo qui va les
mener dans les terres du mordor ou au
contraire quelqu'un qui va simplement se
relever et dire non à quelque chose qui
le touche
eh bien ce sont des choix et vous êtes
soumis comme ses héros au choix alors ça
veut dire aussi que vous aussi vous avez
des choix ouais d'accord mais choix ils
sont pas épique d'accord merci la
boisson à la machine à café ce matin
holt et c'était un choix eh bien oui
c'était un choix comme vous êtes levé du
lit comme vous avez décidé de venir
aujourd'hui quand vous avez décidé de
continuer à vivre avec toutes ces
émotions
toutes ces décisions et tous ses choix
vous avez encore à faire même si parfois
le choix est inconfortable mais alors
comment faisons nous des choix
surtout que quand on est aux joueurs
c'est rare l'importance on pourra ont
passé des heures et des heures et des
heures et des heures à dire comment on
en fait ici il y en a une des visions
qui va nous intéresser
quand vous avez vécu tout au long de
votre vie vous avez fait les connexions
au niveau de votre cerveau vous avez
relier des expériences des émotions des
sensations des sentiments quand vous
avez vécu ses premières expériences
vous avez donc eu les intelligences pas
analytique nécessairement
et ici vous avez amené alors des idées
pensez vous à une nouvelle situation
ouais j'en suis capable non je ne suis
pas capable ou je crois que la seule
idée que j'ai là c'est de m'enfuir a
tout à toute vitesse
ce sont des pensées mais comme aussi je
suis capable de le faire je vais y
arriver c'est possible pour moi ça ce
sont des idées des dialogues que vous
avez établi
associé à ça vous avez tous un corps ou
ce qu'on appelle pour le coup des
sensations quand vous avez ces idées
qu'ils font venir à vous vous avez
également une façon de les exprimer dans
votre corps vous y êtes plus ou moins
sensible plus ou moins sensitif
tout dépend de comment vous êtes à
l'intérieur de votre corps comment vous
vous sentez et en associant ses
sensations par exemple pour certains le
ressenti de la colère pourra passer par
la tête pour d'autres pourra passer au
contraire par levante mais il reste un
troisième élément extrêmement important
qui va créer toutes les connexions et
qui quand on travaille sur cet élément
on peut permettre d'amener de nouveaux
horizons et bien avec ses actions c'est
vos actions vous arrivez au ces motions
et oui parce qu'avec la totalité de ces
trois aspects émotions sensations et
idées vous allez choisir ensuite d'agir
ou ne pas agir
ok il nous a parlé de choc et les appâts
les deux héros joueurs mais séoul a tout
ça parce que pour l'instant il nous a
parlé de choix d'accord donc on est
content des émotions des héros eh bien
vous savez qu'il existe un jeu et toute
ressemblance avec votre vie ne serait
que purement au hasard deux ou non parce
que c'est le livre dont vous êtes le
héros
je sais pas si la plupart d'entre vous
connaissez ce livre vous suivez un
personnage ce personnage va vivre une
suite de récits
davanture tout différent par contre
qu'est ce qu'il va y avoir entre chaque
situation il va y avoir des choix
alors ces choix peuvent être faits à ce
moment là de manière consciente et vous
le faites à ce moment là pour les héros
est ce que le héros en a conscience
c'est une bonne question est associée à
ces choix d'expériences de vie dont vous
êtes le héros derrière il va y avoir des
fins différentes défunt qui peuvent être
différentes selon choix est parfois tous
les choix peuvent mener à la même fin
donc imaginez maintenant que celui dont
vous êtes le héros qui engrange tout vos
expériences toutes les connexions on
leur amène maintenant au principe du jeu
est votre jeu préféré celui auquel vous
à devrait jouer imaginez l'énergie dans
laquelle vous vous êtes quand vous y
jouez imaginer à ce moment-là toute
l'énergie qu'il y ait tout quand vous
êtes en collectif d'ailleurs tout ce qui
peut se passer en contexte ce qui vous
fait avancer avec
et attention et je vais vous demander de
ne pas trop regarder dans la salle les
gens qui seraient tellement impliqué
dans un jeu parfois on pourrait se
demander s'ils ne sont pas en train de
jouer leur vie vous imaginez jouer notre
vie dans un jeu
et pourtant la question qui se pose
alors c est ce que les enjeux de ces
personnes les enjeux du jeu sont ils
encore du jeu au du jeu
à vous de voir ce que vous y mettez
parce que derrière toutes ces personnes
qui par exemple vont jouer leur vie et
le contexte que vous allez avoir en
mettant du jeu en mettant la vie comme
un jeu en reprenant cet exercice vous
allez à ce moment là faire des
associations vous allez changer par
exemple une expérience perçu dans votre
vie qui va pouvoir se rejouer parce que
nous respirons encore chacun et chacune
des séances vont pouvoir se représenter
à un moment donné sous une forme
différente avec un costume et eau
et là c'est la notion de perception
d'émotion parce que ces trois pôles
quand vous décidez d'y mettre de la jl
du jeu vous changer à ce moment là
l'émotion vous changez les sensations
aussi perçu et les idées et qu'est ce
qui va se passer quand vous vous
connectez vraiment à cette énergie
la façon dont vous agissez ou n'agissez
pas au contraire va pouvoir changer
alors c'est parti s'il avait est un jeu
vous avez tous commencer à respirer vous
avez tous eu à un moment donné vos
cartes en main vous pouvez les appeler
compétences vous pouvez les appeler
éducation enseignement philosophie
savoir-être qualité faiblesse nature et
vous arrivez donc sur un jeu de l'oie et
vous écrivez jeu de l'oie comme vous le
souhaitez d'ailleurs pour lequel vous ne
connaissez pas toutes les règles de
chacune des cases et à ce moment là vous
allez jouer avec la vie
et qu'est ce qui va se passer vous allez
avoir la vie qui va se mettre face à
vous dans une situation et vous n'avez
42 en face ça arrive
et si je vous dis que alors que cette
situation pouvait être un s'il pouvait
devenir ainsi et que le 2 qui de temps
en temps pouvait perdre se mettaient à
gagner qu'est ce qui a changé le jeu
auquel vous accepté de jouer
consciemment ou non parce qu'il est une
notion de règles la notion de perception
de valeurs parfois vous pouvez également
oublier la valeur qu'à votre propre
carte ce2 oui ceux de magnifiques
tu peux être joué dans un autre contexte
il y a aussi dans cette notion de règles
justement quand on joue par exemple à la
bataille le 2 et perdant face à l'as par
contre si vous jouez le tarot ou le jeu
du président ce2 devient plus fort alors
vous imaginez s'il a maintenant vous
premier conscience des situations dans
lesquelles vous vous mettez à jouer des
jeux que vous avez accepté sans avoir
pleinement conscience et que vous y
mettiez tout d'un coup un peu de lumière
imaginez alors ce qui va se passer si
vous décidez de jouer autrement de
piocher de nouvelles compétences
nouvelles cartes de mettre un peu de
lumière sur ce que vous n'aviez pas vu
jusqu'à maintenant en plus que quand
même génial c'est que quand on se met
encore à respirer eh bien on peut
continuer à jouer encore encore et les
situations qu'ils sont pareils dans les
entretiens d embauche qu'on rate on peut
encore jouer en faisant différemment
parce que vous imaginez comme celui dont
vous êtes le héros
si vous décidez d'un coup de prendre un
autre choix vous y amener des nouveaux
possibles
enfin j'aimerais vous raconter une
petite histoire parce que je vous parle
de cartes on joue on joue on joue j'ai
beaucoup joué de ma vie j'ai beaucoup
perdu énormément mais j'ai appris aussi
est l'un des plus grands enseignements
que j'ai aussi c'est qu'à un moment
donné dans une période qui était assez
sombre le chômage où je n'osais même
flux percevoir la vague ma propre valeur
alors vous y mettez la carte que vous
voulez il y à un ami alors je n'osais
même plus voir mes anciens camarades de
classe parce que
je n'avais pas réussi sur ma perception
l'époque parce que je n'avais pas les
qualités nécessaires
eh bien il m'a dit la chose suivante tu
sais yves on s'en fiche que tu as fait
quelque chose ou pas si on a envie de te
voir
c'est pour qui tu es et ça je peux vous
dire qu'en termes d'enseignement quand
vous jouez quand vous perdez et que d'un
coup vous rendez compte
autour de vous vous avez des alliés qui
sont là pour vous rappeler que vous êtes
des souverains des souveraines et les
rois et des reines de votre vie je peux
vous dire que le jeu devient d'un coup
plus pimentée alors il était une fois
vous vous rappelez de ses mots ses mots
qu'on peut être présentés en début de
conférence
imaginez maintenant que vous rameniez de
l'énergie du jeu dans ce cas vous faites
alors je n'aurai qu'une chose à dire et
bien jouer maintenant
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]